we are live chair
we can go ahead with the meeting thank
you charles okay
um well welcome everyone to today's
meeting of the panel
um if you have any technical
difficulties during the meeting
then please contact the democratic
services officer on call
who will attempt to assist you today's
officer on call is katie brewer
and the number to call is 577-046
i would ask participants when you are
not speaking please mute your microphone
microphones must only be on with the
participant that's been granted my
permission to speak and to gain my
permission to speak please indicate on
the chat
and i will then make a note and call you
when it's your turn and if i miss you
i'm sure charles will remind me
members before we start the meeting um
it'd be impossible for me to
conduct tonight's meeting without
referencing peter campbell
i'm sure you're all aware that peter
died earlier this week
and to my mind ready peter was mr
scrutiny
he'd been on the scrutiny panel with
unbroken service since 2007
and for the last six years he'd either
been chair or vice chair
the thing about peter was that he'd
always read the papers
he was a tough inquisitor but he was
always fair
and more importantly always good humor
i think that he's a real loss to the
council
he will be sorely missed i've been on
this council a very long time and i have
to say that he's simply one of the best
councillors that i've worked with
and i'm proud to say work with although
we're on different sides of the
political spectrum because
he was somebody that was always looking
for the best from this council
and whether ideas came from his side our
side or wherever
he would support them but equally if you
thought you got something wrong
he wouldn't waste time telling you
so members could we just have a few
moments reflection
on peter's life and his enormous
contribution to planet district council
thank you members i won't ask anybody
else to
to speak at this stage um next week
there'll be
ample opportunity to pay full tribute to
peter and i hope members will take that
opportunity
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls whilst the meeting
is in progress
please also refrain from checking emails
and ensure that you are in the quiet
room
for the duration of the meeting please
note that this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
will subsequently be broadcast on the
internet
please can i ask the members of the
panel to confirm that they are present
in the meeting when i read out your name
councillor boyd
councillor coleman cook president chair
council hopkinson yeah i'm here too
councillor huxley i'm here chair
councillor keane here chair councillor
pat moore
here chair councillor paul moore
chancellor paul moore councillor linda
piper
councillor piper
councillor ratigan
thank you councillor rozeki
and counselor scots here chair
thank you
excuse me chair uh councillor curry here
i've just been added to doing scrutiny
so i'm probably at the bottom
councillor curry how could i forgotten
how could i have forgotten
sorry about that that's okay now thank
you council curry are you here
i think so yeah no good excellent all
right
fine um i've received the following
request to speak under 20.1
it's councillor garner on item nine
yeah i'm here yes are there any more
members who wish to speak
under 20.1 uh
councillor bailey on agenda item 7
please
chancellor bailey okay so i forget you
councillor bailey i'm sure you'll remind
me that you're here
okay thanks item seven lovely thank you
um i've also received a request to speak
from a member of the public that's ms
deb shotton
who's going to speak on a gender item
nine
okay moving on to the agenda uh
apologies for absence
uh have we received any apologies
charles
none that i've received share but i did
notice that in the
uh appointments i sent out counselor
piper declined
so i want to assume it might be an
apology but
she didn't say that directly to me okay
thank you
and obviously we've got a couple of
members who are aren't here at the
moment
but may turn up um
okay right remember
did anybody have any declarations of
interest
i can't see anybody indicating so i'll
take that as a no
agenda item 3 to approve the minutes of
the opium scrutiny panel meeting held on
the 19th of january
copy was attached to the agenda pack can
i have a proposal please
i'll propose that churchill thank you
colin cook in the second
please
i'll second that
thank you okay uh unless i'm here in the
objection i will take these as approved
okay they are approved members i'm
bringing forward
uh agenda item 12 which is the election
of
vice chair we'll take this item first
but then we'll go back to the correct
order of the agenda
and disappeared on a supplementary
agenda
i'm calling for nominations for the
vacant post of
vice chair to the panel to serve the
remainder of the municipal year 2021
now it's convention that this panel is
chaired
by a member of the opposition and the
vice chair is usually
a member of the controlling group so the
the conservative group have no
intention of nominating anybody so do we
have any nominations
yes yes chair i'd like to nominate
councillor alan
i'd like to second that councilor moore
thank you councillor moore do we have
any other nominations
no so as there are none uh then
uh the person counselor curry uh i
believe that makes you duly elected so
welcome to the panel and look forward to
working with you for the remainder of
this municipal year
and who knows beyond that thank you
thank you very much chair and thank you
members
and officers thank you
crew members uh agenda item for dog
public spaces protection order
amendments
i will call on jasmine vickers to
introduce the report
thank you chair i'm just going to share
my screen
so bear with me while i do that
oh
okay i'm hoping everyone can see that
okay
yes okay um
so this is to present uh the reports on
the dog pspo
public spaces protection order proposed
amendment
for 2021.
so we already have a public spaces
protection order in force
uh in relation to dog control
and this covers um dog fouling dog
exclusion and dog control just to
clarify
um and that was adopted uh in on the
25th of october 2017
and extended until the 25th of october
2023
so overall um just to give a brief
update on the background of the dog pspo
um the three-year restrictions have had
a positive impact
um they've had lots of positive impacts
um some of them on the district's
coastal
um bathing water quality uh and the
cleanliness of our beaches
um but also with other dog-related
anti-social behaviour around some of our
other parks and open spaces
the order has also helped um with the
conservation of some of our
really important uh wildlife populations
around thanet and our conservation
designations uh particularly at places
like peguel bay
and so some of the amendments that we're
going to be talking about tonight
are in relation to that particular issue
so we on the back of having um
contact from members of the public some
of our other partner agencies
and from various other sources we
started an
uh consultation on some amendments you
are
in dogs pfpo so the majority of the pspo
will remain the same
as what it has been um so the majority
of
um the rules around that remain exactly
the same
there are three very specific amendments
that we proposed for consultation on
as a result of feedback that we had from
the public
so the following three changes were
proposed as part of a consultation
so the first one was that at westbrook
bay
the currently that the dogs are on a
lead order
there um might be changed to become a
dog ban
just in bathing season
as a result of the consultation the
majority of people voted against
changing it
and therefore we're not expecting to
move forward with any amendment to the
pspo on that
the second amendment proposed was about
pegwell bay
and this was in relation to our
conservation
conservation designations um at that
location
and the fact that we do have some uh
restrictions there
but there has been a call to extend
those restrictions to cover
uh what we refer to as the upper chalk
shore um
so to encompass the whole of of that bay
um
with dog restriction
and the third amendment um was around
activities that could be banned to help
us protect wildlife
um and this again part of this is that
people have complained
um they have seen people um using dogs
to um disturb bird life and other
wildlife
around our coast and so this enables us
to deal with that particular form of
antisocial behavior
and disruption to our important
conservation sites
so options b and c uh
through the consultation were responded
to positively
by the public
and so what we are proposing through
this report
is that the amendments to the pspo move
forward as follows
so we make the amendments with regard to
options b
and c proposals b and c um
about peg world bay extending uh the
restriction there
and about protecting wildlife generally
around our coastline
the amendment around westbrook bay as a
result of people responding and saying
they didn't want to change the situation
at westbrook bay
we're not proposing to take that
amendment forward
so this is just a quick summary of the
levels
of the feedback the percentages so you
can see that for peg well bay
um and for the wildlife protection we
had
quite a clear majority there of people
that supported those proposals
and for westbrook it was a bit it was a
bit tighter in terms of
people who came back agreeing and those
that came back disagreeing
and as a result of that we did suggest
um potentially going back out to a
consultation again
um and in the end
what we are proposing is that we just
accept the results of this consultation
and move forward
we are able to revisit amendments to the
pspo
annually so we can always come back to
some of these issues
and new issues as they arise
and so just to finish up that's our map
currently of where you can take your dog
and one of the things that has been
really positive as a result of the
public spaces protection order
is that actually we came up with this
communications method
and it's been really well received so we
have these maps available at lots of
locations
and people are able to see really
clearly where they can and where they
can't take their dog for exercise
um so hopefully that that's nice and
accessible for the public to be able to
access
and so i'm happy to take questions uh on
the dog pspo now
okay members does anybody
does anybody have a question there's
nobody in the chat at the moment oh
uh i said so see uh cancer scots arrived
okay uh councillor moore has arrived
which is good
uh and linda piper's arrived so i think
everybody's there so
uh in terms of now somebody speaking uh
councillor keane thank you chair yeah um
my question was just uh those posters
look really good and i wondered if we
could have them actually displayed along
the coast so that people
if they turned up at the wrong place
knew where else they could go
yes um so we are currently looking at
reviewing all of our coastal signage so
we have a lot of different
um types of signage around our coast
that we do want to tidy up anyway
um and we do have the maps displayed at
some places but probably not as widely
as we could
um and i don't think they're big enough
at the moment so that is absolutely
something that we are looking to
encompass in a bigger signage review
that we want to get
uh get going with this season
okay thank you uh councillor boyd
thank you chair i apologize my
internet's a bit funny at the moment so
if i do cut out i will try and
come back to it um just a couple of
questions regarding the westbrook cafe
um situation um firstly i wanted to know
how did you engage with the publix it
seemed a lot of it was done by sort of
online or email
um obviously moving forward and clothing
a lot probably allowing is it possible
to do more sort of face-to-face
engagement out there on the base with
the bay users
you know having a an ipad or a tablet or
chromebook or whatever and getting that
um
initial response because i think people
might be more engaging
and secondly how much work was done to
explain
to people the effects that dogs may have
on our blue flag and accreditation
and and the last one is um from looking
at the figures and i've done a ton of
maths
um but 42 and 52 doesn't add up to 100.
um so i just wondered what the
additional um
i think six percent and what they
answered because that makes a big
difference or was it
don't care unsure neither disagree or
agree because otherwise that 52 really
isn't much of a
majority and also particularly if you
look at 259 people in total that's only
about 135 people
um against the 109 which means 15 people
haven't answered so it's too close i
wouldn't say it's an overwhelming
majority
but just those kind of questions really
thank you councillor boyd yes um i will
start with the last question first
um so the ones that the percentage that
is missing is in relation to responses
that were received but they weren't
answering either yes or no so they sat
somewhere in the middle
they gave an opinion on um something
else dog related or
they sat on the fence with it they
didn't indicate either way so they're
the ones that are missing from those
percentages
um but we have got the detail of those
so
although they didn't answer one way or
the other they still gave us important
feedback which
which we have looked at um in terms of
the types of
uh promotion of the consultation
uh this was slightly before i i took
over the enforcement team so
the the feedback that i've had is that
yes they did go out and they did promote
um through all the usual channels that
we would with public consultation
um i think you've probably hit the nail
on the head that the bit that's missing
from that is having somebody
out there and physically engaging with
dog walkers
on the beach and capturing the actual
users
so that's a really interesting point
that we would definitely take forward
for future consultations
we always follow the guidance um that
comes from government
about how to consult and engage with the
public and we do it through our
communications team obviously
um however i do think that with
something like this there's probably
some really specific
and targeted work that we could do
um with those actual users at that
location again so
um yeah but i think it's definitely
learning
for the future and certainly with the
coastal pspa one of the things that we
have tried to do
is even though it has been via email
because of the current situation that we
find ourselves in and
not doing as much face-to-face and
drop-in sessions and things like that
we have done more targeted emails to
people and we have tried to
pick out of the wider consultation
document that's quite
um it's aimed at everyone i suppose
we've tried to pick out and highlight
the issues
for certain groups and email them
directly with that so
targeted uh consultation is definitely
something we're looking at moving
forward and improving on that
thank you councillor piper oh sorry
kerry did you want to come back
uh it was just in terms of um obviously
you mentioned targeted and specifically
about going out and talk to dog walkers
who probably would have a biased
view and so i'll just make sure that you
would talk to you know the average joe
that's walking down the beach and
sally who's got her two kids there or
something like that so it's not going to
be
just dog walkers and that was fun
absolutely yeah beach users was probably
what i should have said
yeah okay okay uh councillor piper
thank you chair my apologies for being
so late there was a technical
hiccup and and so i missed most of your
presentation jasmine
except the um diagram that you showed at
the very
end i thought that was very clear and a
good idea
and if we distribute that a lot i think
along the railings and beaches and so on
um that that would help to clarify
not just dog owners uh but all people
who just like to walk along the beach
they get
quite excited oh is that dog supposed to
be there and if there's a diagram
um i i think that would help residents
who don't own dogs as well
thank you yes
thank you thank you remember i can't see
anybody else wanting to speak
um jasmine you've heard one or two
comments that people have made
and suggestions um but i think uh it's
fair to say that
uh the panel is happy with your proposal
i think which is option one
on the report that's going to cabinet um
is that agreed members i see some
nodding so
what's that oh sorry councillor moore uh
a light entry for a question
yes sorry sorry chair late by nature and
late by this one
um i apologize for being late uh again
it was that's access it was an issue and
i just did miss the presentation
i just confirmed we are just talking
about the dog walkers as this first bit
and there wasn't too much in that first
five minutes that jasmine
gave uh um because i've got issues with
the
pspo uh regarding bay users and that
sort of thing so we have that hasn't
come up yet has it
no you've got plenty of time to work up
to that one and count one more
thank you chad that one's for later
thank you
if you want to go and limber up ready
for your battle with council more later
on
feel free no no we're we're we're
singing from the same hymn page
thank you so thank you jasmine for that
my members moving on agenda item five a
cabinet presentation
an overview of estates and economic
development portfolio areas
um can i welcome councillor duckworth
and invite her to make her presentation
thank you
thank you councillor boys and thank you
for inviting me to talk to you about my
portfolio
um so i have some notes here um
so um i cover my title is economic
development and estates
um which covers i'll just run through
quickly what it covers as well
um so it's economic development and the
officer i deal with mostly on that
is louise askew um climate emergency
um i'm sure that i'm an emergency so i
deal with dr hannah scott basically on
that one
tourism beach management um this crosses
over a lot with cancer albums
areas corporate property and land is
estates
which will come to you later facilities
management
well covered 19's meant that i haven't
done much of this
and building control comes under
planning heritage museums that's
connected to tourism
it's connected to estates and it's
connected to economic development
and regeneration
so economic development
much of economic development in thanet
is connected to external funding
we've also been administrating the
coveted grants provided by government
but that's been done through civica
and overseen by finance um
and so that would be councillor yates is
brief
um and it's all really to do with the
fact that we're a small local authority
so there is
a lot of cross departmental work the
function of economic development crosses
over a number of different service areas
there's the regeneration team so the
team has to focus on economic growth
leveling up including responding to
government releases of funding
the team includes director of
regeneration tourism manager
with a small tourism and visitor
information team
there's a heritage action zone manager
and a project manager
so key current areas of work include the
margate tan deal
which i spent a lot of time on uh
ramsgate future high street ramsgate
heritage action zone using heritage to
support the economy
high street heritage action zone for
ramsgate
and we're negotiating with historic
england to finalize the project
historic england heritage at risk
coveted funding we have
two schemes for just under 25 000 for
polamite repairs in ramsgate
and specialist services to understand
the costs associated with the theatre
royal
we're putting together and delivered the
programme of work
for the reopening of high streets safely
funding allocated by central government
through the erdf
programme tourism
in 2019 tourism contributed at least 352
million to the third economy
each year supporting eight thousand six
hundred and sixty four jobs
these jobs equates about nineteen
percent of than its jobs
we're looking to engage specialist
consultants to understand the options
and feasibility of developments at the
westbrook loggia
this is due to start about the end of
march and will inform the cabinet
of the best options and route to taking
forward the asset for redevelopment
officers have procured specialist
services to put together a feasibility
and options for a beach club in ramsgate
on the marina car park site
this report will come to cabinet for
discussion on the best option and route
to taking the project forward
we're working with kcc growth hub on
programs and initiatives which will
support the local economy post
lockdown right i'll just run through
estates as well so states is really
property and asset management and the
property services covers several areas
of activity
management of the council's commercial
property investment portfolio
where the council receives rental income
from its freehold properties to
contribute towards the overall tdc
revenue
to provide council services this
involves dealing with tenants with
estate management
and repairs issues rent review and lease
renewal negotiations
new lettings of vacant property engaging
local agents
we are currently looking at how to
approach this strategically
to find and implement cost-effective
ways to have more proactive estate
management
meeting best practice asset management
protocol both enhancing rental income
and adding long-term capital growth
management of the councils for sure and
other leisure type properties
and again this tends to overlap with
cancer albums areas
in operations this involves similar
asset management activity although
also having the right type of tenants to
provide services that residents and
visitors seek
influences some of the decisions
liaising cross service with other teams
finding a balance between outright
financial considerations
and the right resident and visitor
provision from local businesses
we also have in-house professional
property services to other
council service areas regarding their
operational property
that could be council offices depots the
port
and many more whether the councillor
council is own occupier tenant or
landlord letting out surplus space
a full range of commercial property and
surveyor services is needed
and provided by the property team this
is sometimes referred to as
the corporate landlord model although in
reality that involves a higher division
between provision of council services
and the provision of property facilities
which some public bodies have adopted
property asset disposals including the
sale of assets on the open market
and also by community asset transfer
so open market property sales are as
agreed by cabinet for a variety of
reasons
raising capital for other capital
expenditure schemes
community asset transfers are done
within the strict guidelines of the
localism act
wall disposals are carried out to
achieve best value
as obliged by legislation
handling the annual asset valuation
using independent surveyors and valuers
are meeting all the statutory
requirements in liaison
with the finance team providing expert
property advice to the council on major
projects
this includes strategic advice on the
council's future corporate occupational
needs
daisy with regeneration colleagues and
contributing the property advice
and negotiations element to upcoming
initiatives such as future high street
funding
the town fund and similar potential
projects
so that's a brief run through of my
portfolio
especially economic development and
estates so happy to take questions now
thank you council duckworth members over
to you
the silence is deafening um cast that
was can i ask you something uh the
tourism figures you gave
um did you say that for 2019
uh i believe yeah say 2019 yep
yeah um do you have any probably you
know a bit unfair in a way but but do
you have any
feel for what 2020 might have been like
well i i i i'll um i
may pass you over to louise askew if
she's here but um
obviously there are a lot of people
coming in 2020
um because of coronavirus we i think we
all noticed that
um because they couldn't go abroad um
how we would measure that i'm not really
quite sure
because there are a lot of people coming
in at parts of parts of the time there
will be lots of people on the beach and
they wouldn't have been able to
there would be no facilities for them
there would be no where for them to go
in terms of spending money so um i don't
know if louise is here and can give any
further i still agreed earlier
yeah i mean we've we've worked really
hard with the sector
and since uh we went into lockdown in
march
and have engaged with them um all
through the period sending out a weekly
newsletter with
information about what's available and
what support there is
and i think it's a mixed picture in
terms of the businesses and how
this has impacted them some businesses
have
um flown in terms of doing
uh takeaway services and and things like
that and others have just kind of
shut down batten down the hatches and
are waiting
um i think the challenge will be that we
have
the majority of our businesses in this
sector are independent and small
and so it does um hit them harder
um but we have been working with um
the businesses in the sector as i said
all the way through to
try and support them where we can and
help them understand
how as we start to come out of lockdown
and how they can be better supported
and we've also been lobbying central
government as well
yeah i mean did do you again probably
not a very fair question
but do you have any feel at this stage
as to whether there are significant
number of businesses that
were unlikely to operate in the future
you know they've gone
forever i mean again this is where where
you know we liaise with finance because
they're
i'm i'm hoping that the grants that have
been available are going to help a lot
of businesses to stay afloat
um it's difficult to you know
it's difficult to say and i think you
know somewhere may have been
having difficulties anyway and it's just
what's tipped them over
you know they might have managed to
survive but
um i don't think we've got anywhere near
figures yet unless there is
a snow no okay and and no
no feeling for for whether you know any
town was
was hit worse than others or did better
than others to
to weather it i think
i think it's just possibly a um
something that we could
uh chairman if you don't mind me just uh
um i think obviously this is probably
some information that we may be able to
obtain
from the uh kcc growth hub because i
know they have been
heavily engaged in providing advice to
businesses and obtaining some data so
and kcc also have uh the economic unit
that they set up so
i i suspect it's something we could put
a request in to
kcc to see what information they've got
on that because i think it's entirely
valid question and does need to
inform some of our approach to recovery
which we're now thinking about
um along with the county um
and as part of those structures i think
part of the challenge
challenge is a lot of the data comes
through the businesses themselves and if
they haven't been functioning and been
open it's quite difficult uh then to be
able to
uh collect it so i suspect it will be
more through
uh activities um that through
phone calls and information that's being
received directly from businesses who
have been looking for advice
i don't know if louise wants you to add
anything more to that but i i think i
don't think we're gonna have perfect
information just because of some of
the usual way we collect it just hasn't
been available for
for that summer from a tourism
perspective we can easily
find out from the businesses because we
work really closely with them
and as mazeline said the growth hub have
been surveying businesses regularly and
we
and we do get that information um
and it and it's challenging i think the
honest
answer to some of that is the unknown
and it's the unknown of
how long those businesses aren't going
to be able to
run as they would have normally and the
impact that the
um social distancing exception will have
in the longer term and the impact on how
people
behave and how you know less people may
want to go out
or or go and stay somewhere else so
that's still a lot of unknowns and i
think businesses are just waiting
thank you um council piper has your
question been answered in the chat by
madeleine
yes it has thank you chair yeah thank
you okay councillor boyd
you had a question thank you chair um
it's just
it's part question part comments um
if cover decides and planet i think has
traditionally struggled in terms of
having the tourism and leisure
extent throughout the year with very
much a summer orientated
um place very much started at the beach
and so i'm just wondering would there be
any work around
how can we promote tourism and leisure
use
within our lovely districts um all year
round so how can we attract people in
the winter so that we still get
commerce coming in um throughout the
year so we're not just solely relying on
those
four or five glorious sunny cells and
obviously we have green land which
sometimes has affected fairgrounds and
things like that but
what else can we do to attract people
here during the winter even if it's not
holidays but it's people from other
parts of kent coming in
and what else can we do and to get that
kind of
all year round business that fun it can
be a busy place all year round
yeah this is something that was looked
at for the margate tandem it's certainly
a key theme
um and i think it should yeah spread
across the whole of than it not just be
for margate
and you know we do need to support our
theaters and indoor leisure
and um obviously we don't get the answer
back from government
until march but um on the market
tan deal specifically um but yeah it's a
very valid point
and uh it's something that we're looking
at all the time i don't know louise
wants to expand on that at all yeah
happy too
i mean in generally we don't um
promote the district during the summer
months our promotion tends to be
around the shoulder periods in the
winter
and we look specific markets that would
be interested in in different things
and do more kind of focused work around
those we work with
um visit kent so we buy into bigger
campaigns
that we wouldn't otherwise be able to
afford on our own um
and you know we work with some of our
bigger organizations as you you
mentioned dreamland
turner contemporary um there's a reason
turner contemporary has different shows
so that they encourage visitors to come
throughout the year we
work with southeastern around special
offers on the trains
um and we are seeing our shoulder
periods
reducing and that peak kind of season
extending
one of our biggest um areas of visitors
is visiting friends and family
um so they're people that do tend to
stay obviously not always in
accommodation but with friends and
family
and and go out and visit um across the
district so
there are a number of things we have a
really small budget and a really small
team
so we try to make the best of certain
avenues
um and and constantly working with
and visit britain and other
organizations to promote
the uh promote the district but we tend
to do less in the summer
um it's more in their shoulder periods
in winter
thank you councillor curry thank you
chair
um yeah i was wondering um have asset
transfers been
affected by covid and will there be a
review of sites that
where there hasn't been any interest i
was thinking in particular
somewhere like um harold road car park
in cliftonville
which giftedville west councillors would
like to retain we think
in the future um somewhere like harold
road car park
um would be a real financial benefit to
the council
thank you um well i have to tell you
alan that um
howard car park is likely to this is
where we you know we sell assets to
raise money
and um i think it's very unlikely
that that will come off the asset
transfer
list i'm afraid um
[Music]
and uh there have obviously been some
delays with with covered i think
um i don't know if rob lodge can explain
and would like to expand on that at all
uh yes good evening everybody and just
to say i've only been here as entering
direct property since the beginning of
october
so obviously part of the um covid
effects that already happened then and
certainly in may my predecessor did
um make the decision to put some of the
asset disposals for 2021 on hold at that
time
others were also put on hold um
for uh political reasons and various
further
uh discussions and i think maybe harold
road was
one of those and um certainly
um we as a team have now been told to go
ahead
ahead
with that and and that will be one of
the disposals that we'll be doing in
the new financial year just to be clear
any disposals we do
are only done with cabinet approval
having been got
first and there is a budget
for disposals next year and we've
identified
how we're going to do that
thank you um councillor paul moore
you've got a question
yes thank you chair and thank you
council duckworth for your um
presentation um i have a query with
regards to
again asset transfers uh in as much as
faunus water ski club i'm not sure if
you're aware
um but this is one of the items that's
come up for disposable
and i believe you're in dialogue with
the directors of that club
um to broker some kind of arrangement as
they they get first choice of refusal
um but also there has been a breakdown
in communication with them for some time
uh and i know that jasmine and i have
had dialogue
yesterday regarding forness water ski
club
and some of the queries they've got and
aspirations they've got and reservations
um can you reassure me that this is
going on that we are liaising with them
to bring this to fruition and also to
possibly also support them as a club
because
they they offer an amenity within our
area which
the foreshores are one of our greatest
assets and it would be nice to see that
the club does remain and does get
supported
but i don't mean that we finance i just
mean that we help them to continue
in what they're trying to do thank you
um i'm going to ask rob large if he can
give any information on that or if it's
something we need to come back to
by email or at a later meeting
uh yes thank you um yes councilman i'll
need to come back to you on that uh
i know one of my team is dealing with a
number of
um situations similar to that and is
liaising with uh
the for sure team uh in in jasmine's uh
service so i'd like to um agree to email
you
back on that in the next couple of days
yes that's absolutely fantastic thank
you very much well
thank you okay um hang on
oh counselor you've got a question
uh yes thank you um just like to ask
about
develop developer contributions um
how are they calculated and what impact
have they had
because obviously uh with covid that
might have had a
bit of a slowdown but do you have any
information on that please thank you um
i don't know exactly how they're
calculated i i don't know whether
there's a sort of county
or national formula and i don't know if
ian livingstone's still here
to advise um it was really a bit more
about
economics and estate so he may not be
here to advise on that so again
i think that's more opinion matter
rather than yes
yeah but ian is here
there was a slowdown of some starts uh
in and around the district
um and obviously the triggers for
developer contributions
uh are often related to either prior to
occupational prior to actually starting
on sites
um but actually what we have found over
the past um
certainly past six months is that there
have been more uh
sites being completed um and indeed more
more development going on mainly from
sme builders
that are that are operating in the
district which has actually meant that
we are
now the point where we have quite a few
triggers being hit on developer
contributions
um and indeed there is going to be
further information that's going to be
coming out
um in the next month um in the form of
an infrastructure funding statement
which will provide more details about
this
for the financial year 19
2019 sorry to 2020 um
which i mean it doesn't cover the
covered crisis but it just before that
within the subsequent infrastructure
funding statement which will come out at
the end of this year
which will cover then the covered period
of 2020 to 2021.
i hope that answers the question
yeah thank you thank you thank you
okay um i can't see anyone else could i
i just got one last question
um maybe again directed to rob rather
than
anyone else um are we happy that we're
completely up to date with rent reviews
on all the properties that we own
rob
uh the short answer to that um council
rayford is no
uh and it's something that i'm looking
into
uh having been in this interim role for
uh
four months now um but um due
uh mainly to a human resource uh
problem and to pressing needs
for the estate and all and all the items
of activity that council
duckworth highlighted
those dealing with those rent reviews
and lease renewals
which in some cases will include an
increase in rent
some cases they may not um is
running behind and it's a problem that
we're aware of
and looking at ways to address
okay i mean is there any possibility
that we might use outside resources i'd
rather that there are
specialists that deal in management of
leases and
rent views and so on is there any
possibility we might use those
um council both of that i don't think we
should go into too much detail in this
uh meeting i might suggest but i can
certainly
be that that is one of the options and
that i have done initiatives
when i've been an interim director in
other local authorities where there's
been a similar problem
so that's one of the things um that i'm
in the process of discussing with tim
willis
and madeleine thank you i consider
myself shut up
so thank you for that
members i i can't see any other any
other people
indicating that they want to speak so uh
councillor duckworth can i thank you for
coming along this evening for your
presentation
and louise and rob and ian i know you're
going to be doing something later but
thank you for your contribution to this
agenda item so thank you very much my
pleasure thank you very much thank you
we move on to agenda item six
where do we have a charles
chief inspector pepper here
yet we do indeed ah
excellent okay right
so agenda item six crime stats in thanks
so i will now call upon chief inspector
rhiannon pepper to make your
presentation thank you
okay uh good evening everyone thank you
ever so much for the invite tonight
i think they've just been shared so for
those of you that don't know me i'm um
chief inspector rhiannon pepper i took
over as district commander in november
previously i've been in out of thanks
over my 20-year careers in various
different roles
i was born in red and then it so i have
a real strong affiliation
to the area and obviously having worked
in there i know some of the
unique challenges that we get from
thanet
so tonight what i've done i prepared and
it's just a short overview of
our crime and asb statistics um
so if we're going to the first slide so
the first one is victim-based crime
obviously one of the most important ones
the good news is that actually we are
slowly decreasing
the trend in the volume of victim-based
crime so
if you have a look between 2018 and 2019
we had 130 crimes per thousand
population for victim-based
we are now on 122 122.6 crimes per
a thousand population
you can see and it's no surprise for
anyone we do always during summer
periods
see a rise towards victim base crime
and that despite the lockdown and
despite
having less uh people out and about
in the public arena we still saw that
during the summer months
and we'll come on to that but that was a
lot to do with
uh up to 10 000 people per day on their
beaches a lot of crimes that were
reported
that were from people that were
transient coming into the area just for
the day then leaving
so if we're going to slide two
so when we break down victim-based crime
for those of you that
don't know about it it based down into
different crime groups
not surprisingly the biggest percentage
is going to be violence against a person
and if you have a look it's 51
however what we have seen and again
really really positively
is that our arsenal and criminal damage
we've seen a reduction
we've seen a reduction in burglary we've
seen a reduction in robbery
a reduction in sexual offences and again
we have seen
a reduction in violence against a person
although it still remains one of the
biggest
areas we have however seen an increase
in theft
and theft from vehicles and i'll come on
to that
so no if we go back sorry so taking over
in november obviously my main concern is
the violence against the
person so that's what i've been
concentrating on and what we've done
is every single month we've been a
violent intensification week
and that's i've got my own resources
i've got county resources
and for an entire week we'll be looking
and just to give you
some of the highlights from that um last
week we had the violent intensification
week
we went to an address and it was just um
uh
caller come in saying they're concerned
about mail at the address um
they believe there's been cuckoos so for
those of you that don't know that
terminology it means
somebody has moved into that address and
taken advantage of him
we've attended three people have run out
and we've detained them
one of those was wanted from murder on
the mets two days previously
and come straight down to thenet we
found 30 000 pounds worth of drugs
and they've been charged
also within the intensification weeks
we've arrested outstanding sexual
offenders
high-risk domestic abuse we've done
various warrants for drugs and county
lines
and we've targeted our organized crime
groups so we've actively on those weeks
we've been looking at targeting
those that are causing the most high
harm in our communities
part of it as well is around the
speaking at
speaking to people speaking to the use
understanding why people carry knives
understanding why
people would um think that violence is
a way to deal with issues so we've been
going out doing the high visibility
obviously kovid has made it more
difficult to do that engagement with the
use but our youth engagement officers
are still
pumping those messages out trying to get
the understanding around
what would happen if you found with a
knife and the impact that's going to
have on you
long term should you be arrested in
possession of a knife
we had our amnesty bins and we had a
record 74 knives recovered in january
when we put them out where people have
voluntarily placed their knives away for
us to recover
um as part of the victim intensification
week we actually
one of the days was domestic murder in
cliftonville so the officers that had
come on to deal with
syria's violence were actually dealing
with that domestic murder
so that's part and that's going to
continue we've done it every single
month a week
each single month we'll do that and
we'll really concentrate on those real
high harm criminals so we talked about
everything was going down apart from
theft and vehicle offenses
now last year than it's had a real issue
with
moped thefts and theft motor vehicles
there was five use that single-handedly
committed hundreds of fences stealing
mopeds burning them
destroying them they have all been
charged and they're all going to court
in january we started seeing a little
bit of a trend as well from theft from
motor vehicles
so again using my proactive policing
teams
community policing team and margate task
force we
looked at the areas that these farms
have been committed we actually got some
specialist assets down our track
cars and our trap assets and we got
directed surveillance
and we located the offender and again he
was charged and minded to court and we
actually found out
where the uh where he was selling on and
who was handling
all those steps for motor vehicles so
although there was a massive jump last
year i am
quite confident that when i speak to you
this time next year we're not going to
see that because
any pattern in now as soon as i start
seeing any passing in i am putting the
resources onto it
we talked about uh theft
theft uh shoplifting has gone up across
the east in fact across kent
um we've got town beat officers now in
each town we've got the western cross
officers
and again we work really closely with
our partners we work really closely with
stores to try and target those repeat
thieves in order to make sure that we
deal with them in fact
in this week alone we have remarded
we've dealt with and remanded
two prolific thieves so it's something
that we are taking seriously
um going back to the violence against a
person
again one of the one of the things when
i started looking at fan inside looking
at the statistics one of the problems i
found we have
quite a high rate of domestic abuse um
and our call rate
so we've got five districts in the east
and
then it takes 28 of all calls so our
call volume is much higher than the
other districts
but out of that we actually take a
higher than normal um
amount of domestic abuse calls but we
weren't getting the charges and we
weren't we're getting very high
victim declines so first thing i did
when i arrived at that was to actually
look into that and say
why why we not seeing uh victim
engagement and we put a eight-point plan
in
and that was all around making sure our
officers now
as soon as they attend there they will
not leave until they've got a statement
another officer will come and convey the
prisoner and we'll stay with that victim
get the statement get the best evidence
and that has really changed our charge
rate but more important to our charge
rate
is our ip decline rate has dropped
significantly because people have that
confidence we're staying with them we're
talking
we're getting that best evidence and
pushing it through so moving on to the
next slide
so antisocial behaviour
again you can see from the grass we had
a very
high call demand in april and may and
again haven't looked through that
what we didn't do was change our covet
calls so
the increase that we have includes all
the cover calls where people quite
rightly are phoning us to tell us that
there's a problem as people are
gathering that people are
going out of houses so we saw a massive
increase
in april and may we've also seen a big
increase in january
again that is covert calls but we've had
december and january we've had two
specific problems in thanet we've had
leopold car park and arlington house
both have received repeat calls about
skateboarders and nuisance use
in november kent um initiated
the pco task force and that is a task
force you can bid for a month period
to come down and they come down group of
officers and deal with issues with you
and they do the asara plan
prob themselves but look at the
long-term effects so rather than just
paying lip service what are the
long-term effects
so we bid in for them for ramsgate and
we've also
within thanet we've also got a pcso
proactive team
so we've got six pcsos that again we can
parachute into problem areas so getting
there on the early doors start dealing
with the issues and dealing with the
underlying issues as well so
when we have nuisance used it's okay so
obviously lock down while you're out but
actually what is the cause of that what
is the home life
what other things can we put in place
for them and
what i can say is quite a significant
drop in the course at arlington house in
fact we're going to closing down the
problem profile because we've had so few
calls
since we put the pcsos in place and the
same with the rams gates
if we move on
so nighttime economy it was a bit
different last year as we said
because of covid however from the
clustering and it would be nice surprise
to anybody that
has lived or worked in thanet is that
you're still seeing that clustering
around the ramsgate area
what i've done in anticipation for this
summer and
understanding the what potentially could
happen with the lockdown
is i've looked at the shift patterns of
my officers i've changed the shift
patterns of my officers to make sure
i've got them at the peak periods
so that we can have additional resources
at that time
when we know that we are going to be hit
with either violence against a person or
anti-social behavior
we've got the analytical work behind it
so that each week i will get a breakdown
to see where the issues are
and then i can continue to look to make
sure i'm putting people in that right
place
as well as forward thinking because
again as i say i've come from thanet
i've worked in thanoc for many years
i can tell you the dates that we are
going to see a surge in fact most people
here can tell you the dates that we're
going to see a surge because we see it
every single year during the same
period so by knowing that in advance
i've already changed the shifts
i've already put additional resources on
to make sure we can meet that demand as
it comes through
if we're going to the next one
next one is hate crime
so again when i came over
when i came back to thanet one of the
problems i saw was with the hate crime
and we weren't
getting we were getting increase hate
crime but we weren't actually
getting um a lot of charges from that
again we're getting a lot of vip
declines
so they'd call it call us in tell us
about their crime
but then they'd not want to prosecute
and i wanted to understand the reason
behind that
and i work with the dci who's in charge
of the overall hate crime
and we've actually put in the team now
just for hate crime because we
understand the impact
hate crime has on the victim and it does
have a
real impact and if we don't have the
confidence of that victim
then they're not going to engage with us
they're not going to tell us about
further crimes
and we're not going to be able to deal
with the offenders because
what we know is in december we had one
person that committed
eight hate crimes we need to deal with
that person we need to deal with them
robustly so we've now got a set team
that looks
at the hate crime and each day i'll
review it so each day
part of my analytical products that come
through i'll look at that hate crime and
i'll see
what's coming overnight make sure it's
allocated make sure that my community
liaison office is updated
but most importantly looking at that
patterning so have we got repeat victims
have we got repeat offenders
what can i do to try and reassure the
community that we are taking this
seriously
next slide stop and search
i think this is an incredible
tool and one that we must use but we
must use wisely
so within our stop and search our
independent police advisor group which
we have within thanet
we will talk about our stop search and
we'll give an example of a stop search
and we'll take it from start to finish
and we'll talk with the independent
group about
what they think we should have done what
they think we did right what they think
we did wrong and then we
share that um but that's also done
within um the county as well so
our stop searches will go to the county
ipad
as well and again you'll have laypersons
that will look and they'll look at the
body one they'll look at how the
officers interacted did they use correct
terminology
did they have the law lawful power to do
it and so each stop and search is
scrutinized
each stop and search we carried out has
to be authorized by the person
supervisor
and they have to outline the ground and
the reasons and what was found
majority of our stop searches as you can
see are done
for misuse of drugs in fact the
vast majority of our stop search is done
from extrusive drugs
uh we have the pace and that is normally
going to be your weapons
so we're stopping you because we believe
that you've got a weapon upon you and
we'll go into weapons
next but the vast majority of stock
searches within thanet are
because of drugs where we believe that
person has drugs on them
what i wanted to do here is just
reassure people that there is scrutiny
over our stock search there is
scrutiny not only with the independent
police but internally as well
so each month i will dip test for these
stop searches and make sure
that i am happy with the circumstances
i'm happy with the bodybuild video i'm
happy that the officers have done
everything within their power and that
is lawful
so the last slide is around knife driver
as you can see we had a big jump in
december with knife crime
and that was actually youth on youth
crime
and that was um you've been
asked to come and meet a drug dealer to
buy drugs
and as they turned up the drug dealer
would then turn an eye from them and
they take their money again working with
our youth
uh groups working with our pcsos
we got that messaging out there and we
actually again
were very fortunate to locate and arrest
a couple of people that
were dealing with those robberies
however although that looks quite high
what i need to say is that we've changed
the recording system as well so
if you reported the crime to me and you
said
saw an eyesore knife in their hand that
would be recorded
as a knife instant even if it later
transpires there wasn't a knife in their
hand
criminal damages if a sharp instrument
is used to damage a vehicle
that is recorded as a knife crime so
the statistics statistics don't really
reflect
our actual knife crime and each week we
have a performance meeting and we go
through the knife climbing than it
um and we'll break down knife prime
actually where the knife has been used
and then knife crime where knife has
been mentioned not seen
and other incidents i.e the criminal
damages where something sharp has been
used
the attention on knife prime again
i look at it i pass it out to my
inspectors i want an update anybody
that's found with a knife anybody that
uses a knife
i'll expect an update the next day about
what's happened with them
if they've been released under
investigation
then why that was why we haven't put
bail conditions on them
if they've been released without charge
then that's a full report to me
so that i am satisfied that those that
are carrying knives and again at risk
themselves and to others we are dealing
with um appropriately
i appreciate that was a whistle top to
stop i can't
speak now i appreciate that was a quick
um run through statistics and i'll open
up to questions
yeah thank you very much really really
interesting um
somebody uh who's not actually in the
meeting has come up on the
sidebar and asked whether it would be
possible
when you're going into a place one of
your targeted
days if ward councillors could be
advised
uh that it's happening and what uh
what you're targeting as you're going in
would that be possible
i could do it after the days but
obviously as i'm sure you can appreciate
a lot of
ours is sensitive information especially
when we're talking about the organized
crime and we're talking about the
drug dealing so we wouldn't necessarily
say
prior to doing it but what we could do
is as part of our debrief at the end
of the week is actually put it out to
the councillors to say we've been on
this address um without the address
we've been on this location and this is
what we've
found so i could easily incorporate that
as part of our debriefing
system if that would be useful for
people lovely i'm sure it would thank
you
um councillor boyd
hi thank you for your um presentation um
it was just a quick question
as we are now in very much a virtual
world
using our computers a lot more and as to
whether there's
any work around splitting the data about
if there's any changes on
online crime and i won't say online
crime was in
anything from scams screaming um
you know puppies being miss sold and all
of that kind of stuff so i wondered
whether there was anything specific to
planet
um a month i know it's probably quite
difficult um
but whether there's there's any kind of
data we've seen an increase in it
and also how can we keep our residents
safer along that front
i haven't seen an increase per se um
obviously we put out via neighborhood
watch we put out via twitter and via
facebook
around recently we had the covid where
people were being asked for their
details for covid
so whenever we get anything we do try
and put it out across the
open media to make people aware um but
again that is
that is a good point i've not seen and i
am
a slave trust me to my analytical work
every day
i have not seen any pattern in but if
there was passing
as well as putting out neighborhood
watch i could quite easily i'll get a
list of all the councils and make sure
that the council is aware as well so if
we see
um we've had it previously where people
have been knocking at the doors offering
to do services
to vulnerable victims if we see that
drawing a specific area
as well as putting out towards thanet we
can specifically give it to the
councillor so that they can
warn their um persons
brilliant thank you and just in terms of
any proactive
materials particularly safeguard i'll
see children and young people you
mentioned cocoon which is very much a
physical thing but
again using online and web chats to hook
up so if there's anything
that we can use to promote keep of these
uh our younger residents safe so they
don't fall into county lines as well as
the other element of potential grooming
as well you know like in the news today
about google and
stuff like that and so i just wonder if
there's any other materials we can
potentially use and promote on our
socials to parents and schools and
things like that
you know there is and again i can get
that and i can get that sent
out but also um fortunately we aren't
we're going back in school so police are
going back into schools
um it was a real shame when we came out
of it and we are going back into schools
and part of that will be
looking at child sexual exploitation
making people aware of the dangers
um but certainly we do have some
products that i can send out
thank you okay uh councillor
uh yes thank you for your presentation
it's um
it's always a bit alarming seeing
statistics like that but thank you
anyway
um a couple of questions i got my ward
is for the sanic villages
and uh um you didn't give any statistics
for the sonic villages and i am aware
that there's probably
virtually no crime in the area but do
you you gather statistics on the thani
villages
and secondly on the domestic violence
um you've you've got the crimes against
people
but or the victim crime but i wonder if
you keep separate
or or whether we could be presented with
the
breakdown of the statistics for domestic
crime domestic violence because i
suspect
you know the media have been read hot on
the fact that has probably been
increasing
okay thank you okay with regards to the
um
villages yes we do and um i'm aware my
pcos
come to the village parish councils and
they present on
the crimes that have happened as you say
they are quite
low numbers if i was to put every single
ward in there i think it
would probably take us too long and so
what i've done is done the main wards
where we have the biggest issues but
certainly within thank villages i know
we collect their data and that we do
give that data back on a regular meeting
basis um regarding the breakdown of
domestic abuse
i can do that we have victim-based crime
so we put it all in towards victim-based
crime but what we do do
is separate that towards domestic abuse
and
um the other violence against a person
so again that's something that
if you'd like me to come back and
present on i could easily do that and
then i can talk through
what we're doing around trying to
safeguard domestic abuse victims
okay thank you yeah just to say i when i
attend the uh
the the parish council meetings and yes
the ptsos do give us a breakdown of
of the crime as you said none of it is
very serious it's usually a little minor
theft or something but so thank you
anyway thank you
hey councillor scott oh good evening uh
yeah many thanks for the
presentation it's always a good sort of
getting a broad idea on the numbers
um one of the key things that i always
wanted to do prior to the lockdown was
uh
sort of engage with our pcso um sort of
have a walkthrough of that particular
person i think it was a
jake or a jack angel at the time i was
getting name wrong
so apologize on that but um what i did
want to try and do is
have that sort of walk around in my
water i represent the west gate ward
um i mean obviously with the lockdown
being what it is
and covid when can that sort of
situation be looked into if that can be
arranged um
also just something that um counselor
roper pointed out is
we don't actually get a report for our
sort of parish meetings regarding uh
pcso so that would be very welcome
um the only other thing which is a bit
of a question what's um
one of the things that you pointed out
was uh sort of stop and search
uh with especially drug-related misuse
westgate has been sort of a notorious
point where
margate is normally the place where sort
of the the dealers from londoners
would often have come down to actually
uh
deal within the actual district of
phanet um it's been sort of in the past
couple years now been seen as west coast
is the place that they would get off
it's quite a quiet station
and it allows them these particular
dealers to use their bikes and then
distribute within the family area so i
just didn't know if that is it
still i think there was a task force so
i know you give them very
entertaining names so i don't know what
project or what it was called
i just didn't know that still been
undertaken so i think that still might
be
the case where you you're probably
finding a footfall of these uh
dealers using sort of westgate at the
quieter stations such as berchten as the
uh the port of call
so i didn't know if there was a bit of a
an uptake on that
thank you um so regarding your first
point i would actually really encourage
obviously not join this period but once
covid has lifted the restrictions of
change for people to come out with their
local either pcso or town beat officer
depending on what
walls you are i do really encourage that
and when we can i encourage people to
come on um
drive alongs come out with the local
police and teams to actually
understand some of the challenges of the
policing and get a feel
as they're going through for some of the
issues that are faced by the residents
um within then so i definitely encourage
that for everybody
regarding um the train stations as part
of the intensification we work with btp
and we do go to the different stations
to
target them because again we know as
soon as you show a police presence
at margate they'll start coming off at
the other stations we also know
as you said that the quieter stations
especially when the schools are in so if
you're looking
at um westgate
westgate when you've got the two main
schools there that is
a key point for people to jump out and
start
trying to sell drugs so it's very much
on our radar and we do have
various different task force as you said
with all different names
um dealing with our key areas
okay yeah thank you um yeah and when we
do so we'll come out this lockdown i'll
be very much interested in
the ride-alongs and obviously it can
assist the police in any way so thank
you and keep up the good work
council curry
thank you chair um yeah thanks for your
presentation um i'm a ward councillor in
cliftonville west and we found the the
market task force multi-agency
visits really useful and really sort of
helpful
i was wondering are there any plans or
later in the year
obviously you know post lockdown
for these visits to begin again thank
you
funny enough i'm actually sat in the
office with um penny and we were
discussing this earlier saying
um obviously at the moment because of
the restrictions it's making it
quite difficult but moving forward they
have a real impact
having all the different agencies there
that can deal with all the different
problems that emerge is
really really useful so it's definitely
something we'll be doing taking forward
okay i can't see anybody else wanting to
speak
so can i just thank you very much for
coming along this evening
giving up your time to be here and um
wonder if you'd be prepared to come back
in the not too distant future and give
us a bit of an update
and perhaps something that that we've
had in previous presentations is
sort of some comparisons between sanit
and and other places in kent
you know that you know the differences
between them in terms of crime and
you know perhaps some idea of why that
might be and anything that can be done
about that so
um there's a challenge would you be
prepared to
to pick it up and run with it absolutely
i cannot say no to any challenges
so uh no absolutely more than happy to
come back and talk about it and whatever
you want
whatever you want to know about just let
me know in advance and i can make sure
that my presentation reflects that
that's fantastic so on behalf of the the
panel can i thank you very much for
coming along tonight thank you
members moving on agenda item seven for
sure and coastal public spaces
protection order
uh jasmine you're on again um
i think you're going to be covering a
lot of the stuff that was in the members
briefing the other night
so um if you want to sort of gallop
through it fairly quickly i think most
of us are familiar with
the content um that would be great thank
you
thank you very much chair um i'm just
going to present and yes i'm not going
to
um present the whole
presentation that i did at members
briefing i'm going to summarize it and
i'm going to give
members a bit of an overview of some of
the feedback from the consultation that
we've had so far
which i think might be useful and
informative hopefully
so you should all be able to see
slides now
okay um so just to briefly introduce it
to everyone
um we are proposing to introduce a new
beach and coast public spaces protection
order
and a coastal code of conduct so
previously we have bylaws
and this will replace those old bylaws
so the intention and the reason why we
want to do this is obviously to create a
safer beach environment for everyone
for our residents but also for our
visitors uh
and our staff and officers as well um
through deterring and reducing
anti-social behaviour
um but also lots of other undesirable
activities which we get an awful lot of
complaints about in the summer season
so as with the dog pspo it's valid for
three years
after which point uh we would look to
extend it
or do something different or change and
amend it
and the fixed penalty notices that we
can issue under this legislation are
currently set at 100 pounds same for
dogs
and so we're keeping that consistent
so over the recent years um i think the
complaints around
problems with uh usage around our
coastline have increased and this is
probably
um as a result of having lots more
visitors to our coastline which is
fantastic
and but it also comes with another set
of problems
so having a separate code of conduct as
well will really help us address some of
the issues
um and hopefully you know help out our
local businesses as well
who who are working along the coastline
so obviously the main um justification
for pspo is around antisocial behaviors
so all of the things that we have
included in here can be linked to some
form of
anti-social behavior or they affect
people's enjoyment of their home or the
coastline
and the natural environment
interestingly most of the content hasn't
changed from our old bylaws
we might have reworded it and made it a
bit clearer and brought it up to date
because the wording of the bylaws was
quite antiquated
but fundamentally there are very few
changes
some of the key changes we are making or
proposing to make are around the water
user group rules
and pwc usage and most of the time when
we talk about pwcs we're referring to
jet skis because they're the most common
things that we see
around our coastline but it does cover
all pwc's not just jet skis
so the again the the focus that we are
going with with this pspo is not um
that we are going to be really draconian
and hands out lots of fixed penalty
notices
um this is a new set of rules that we're
bringing in for people and it wouldn't
be reasonable to
um dish out lots of tickets um and not
do a lot of education and in informative
work as well
so the key points that we're focusing in
on are making sure that the rules of the
coast are really clear because that's
something that's missing at the moment i
feel
um so we do have a lot of rules and
expectations for coastal users
and usually there's a really good
justification behind those
often to keep people safe but we need to
make sure that everyone understands it
the next thing is telling people what we
expect from them but also what they can
expect from us
so making sure that we are putting out
posters signs
social media and lots of other creative
methods
to make sure that people can access the
information
and that's easier for our residents but
less easy for visitors so we need to
look at a whole raft of different
communications methods
which we're capturing within a within a
communications plan
and we're trying to use things like qr
codes because obviously
since covid's people are much more
familiar with using things like that
as well as traditional methods of
communications obviously
being present and visible is the is the
other key
issue that we need to address so
obviously having lots of patrols going
around so tdc offices
but also utilizing our other existing
staff and partners
and making sure that we're all giving
out the same messages and we're all
telling people the same thing
so consultation feedback today the
consultation is still running at the
moment so obviously we're expecting to
have a few more responses
in um we have had largely
um positive response with regards to our
changes to
um jet ski and and where they can launch
from
and the rules that we are setting to
bring in around those
um canterbury are also embarking on some
changes to jet ski usage in their
district
so uh it's all coming together in quite
a quite
timely fashion we do work with the other
neighbouring councils as well
as part of the coastal safety
partnership so um
we are doing lots of other things to
look at how we can link up around
around the east kent coast the bbq
proposals as well as the other key
fundamental change of
the rules and that's been welcomed as
well so the change
is proposing that we unify um the rules
around barbecues across our beaches and
bays
so you can't barbecue anywhere until
after 6 pm
so clarity has been asked um a lot of
our feedback
feedback has been around um people
haven't quite grasped maybe the full
detail of the rules and they're asking
for clarification on that
um so again it's it's around things like
electric bikes
um we're not banning electric bikes at
all um we're just
issuing people with some separate um
guidelines around how to use them safely
um and so some of these things are going
to be captured within
a follow-up document after the
consultation which will answer some of
these
questions and we'll do some faqs and
clarifications so people are aware that
we've
listened to what they're saying through
the consultation
one of the other things that that came
out of members briefing the other
evening
is um you know some some questions
around the forness water ski club and
and i've had a a good discussion with
council and more about this
really productive and again there's some
really easy things that we can we can do
there moving forward to clarify
um clarify what goes on at that club and
how we work
to support them um
and then we've also looked at something
this week that's come up which is around
obstructions on our promenades and that
could cover a whole multitude of things
but it could be tables and chairs that
are out in the wrong place and they're
causing obstruction which is then
leading to
uh people um having to dismount when
they don't need to and
lots of lots of issues around um
obstructions to the prom
so that's something that we're looking
to include in one of the sections
so feedback from members after the
briefing and during the briefing
on tuesday um were really useful um
targeted enforcement operations was one
of the suggestions
and i think that's a really good idea so
where we've got a hotspot for example
um such as barnes car park we've got a
lot of jet ski launching that goes on
there so that that would be an example
of a place that we could target some
action
at um and then monitoring obviously of
the enforcement activities and the
softer interventions will take place
but one of one of the members suggested
that we publicize those
um and share share it as a kind of um
news story so i think that's really
important as well to show the public
that we're making progress with this and
it's having an impact
mobile cctv was another thing that was
raised which we can absolutely do
to help deal with those those things
mentioned previously
arrangements at the fullness club i've
mentioned and some of the other things
that came out
of discussion were about things like
marker boys
um and bins and um the situation with
parking at botany bay and
a whole load of other really operational
issues which
um are linked to the pspo
but we're capturing all of those things
separately in our beach management plan
for for the season
so um that will probably be a separate
member briefing at a later date
um but we will we will give people a bit
more information on
um all the other stuff that isn't isn't
exactly
uh specific to the pspo
so some of the potential questions um
that members tonight might be interested
to ask and and these are based on some
government guidance around
you know what what members can ask um
around pspos being brought in and so
i'll just run through these really
briefly
uh and then i will i will hand over to
to members
for any other questions um so the first
one is around
evidence um that the anti-social
behavior or the issues
uh are unreasonable so what we've done
with this particular pspo is we've asked
all the officers involved
to collate information and evidence
and we've got lots and lots of emails
from over the years and last year in
particular
which we're keeping um filed and ready
um
to explain our justification for all of
the items that are in there
and one of the questions that we have
been asked is why a pspi
and and why not you know look at some
other way of addressing the problems
um the issue with the bylaws was partly
the the process for dealing with people
who breached them
was much more lengthy legal process the
ability to issue a fixed penalty notice
is a
swifter way of dealing with a persistent
uh problem
um but also the general um ethos around
pspo being linked to antisocial behavior
and people's enjoyment of the coastal
environment
or their home um really seems to fit for
the type of issues that we have around
the athanic coast so
again um we are looking at um
not doing you know disproportionate
issuing of fines
to people um we're looking really at
educating informing and then challenging
behaviors
and then resulting to fix penalty
notices when we absolutely have to when
that when the
you know the um people aren't compliant
with what we're asking them to do
and we have the teeth to be able to
issue those
through bringing this pspo in
alternative approaches um so again other
councils
will stay with the bylaw approach
because they want to include
more things in in their set of rules um
but we feel that the pspa for thana is
is the right
the right tool moving forward and we
have it for other things already so it
it seems to be um more consistent with
things
like the dog pspo and our
alcohol-related anti-social behavior
pspo as well
will the proposals alleviate each of the
problem behaviors
we expect this to have a significant
impact um through the promotion
of it being a new a new set of rules and
a new thing that we're bringing in
we think that alone will have some
impact
on improving um situations and issues
around the coast
but again the combination of really
targeted education
and challenge of behaviour we think will
really help to alleviate
most of the problems in here
exemptions so people that might be
exempt from it as with the dog pspo
all of those things are captured within
our equality impact assessment
um we have considered considered those
for specific issues
um and in terms of unintended
consequences
i think displacement of behaviors is
probably the the biggest thing that we
could really pick up on
um that might be an unintended
consequence
we do have the option to amend the pspo
within the three-year period so if
something did come up that was a there
was a huge issue that hadn't been
you know picked up on and we have the
ability to
to do something about that impact on
different groups
um but the main group impacted by this
will be
the water user group but very specific
members of the water user group
and outside of that there will be fairly
little change on people that are
already using the coastline responsibly
this is about dealing with
problem behaviors and antisocial
behaviour
um so the last few questions that we've
sort of tried to cover off
are um consultation outcomes and other
evidence
um we're collating it all as we go and
we're trying to respond to people as we
go and address certain issues
um and just kind of allow any fears that
might come up we've had a couple of
people
asking you know does this mean we can no
longer use a particular location for a
particular activity and we're saying
no not necessarily um there are
certain caveats within the pspo for
activities like events
or filming activities or organized clubs
and groups
um who have the right risk assessments
and insurances in place to
to make sure everything's done safely so
um
again it's it's um it's not necessarily
black and white that there are ways that
we can work with local groups and local
people to find ways around some of the
issues
um how will it be enforced so this was
the
the biggest question that people have
really asked us um
and how are you going to resource it so
so these final two questions
we will have a designated officer who
will be working this season
um and we'll this is a trial we'll see
how how we get on with this post
um it will sit within the enforcement
team um
they will be focused on the beach and
coast pspo only
just that and just coastal issues uh
however they will have the backup of our
dog warden
and our dog warden will be focused on
the coast this summer and because that's
where our biggest area of need
not to say they won't get called off to
other places from time to time but
their focus is going to be on patrolling
the coast and that's in response to
feedback
that people want to see you know the dog
warden out there and um
you know encouraging people to do the
right thing and and use the right
locations for exercising their dogs
and dealing with dog fouling which is
the other big problem we have
um but we will also have our education
enforcement officer who will be out
there as well
and both she and the dog borden will be
able to enforce under this pspo so
that's three offices
um we're currently exploring our civil
enforcement offices and how they might
be able to
enforce the pspo as well as their
parking responsibilities
because we recognize that a lot of the
time especially in the summer when
they're focused on coastal car parks
they're out there and they will witness
other activities taking place that they
could deal with
um and then we are also um expecting
that due to
due to kovid's situation continuing and
encouraging
recovery of local businesses and
supporting the public
uh through the covid recovery that we
will have covered
wardens out and about and again that
their presence will be focused around
the coastline because it's where our
biggest
issues with um social distancing and
non-compliance will be
and so they will be able to issue out
advice and guidance
and challenge behaviors um in relation
to this pspo as well so
our general intention is to have a lot
more visible presence around the coast
uh this season so
um that's pretty much all of it i'm not
gonna go through the whole presentation
that i went through
um on tuesday night um so i will um
stop now and take any questions from
members
jasmine thank you very much for that um
i've got to say i think this is probably
a first i think you're the first person
who's brought their own
scrutiny questions along with them and i
hope that you set a precedent because
that'll make life so much easier for us
going forward so
so thank you for that uh counsel more
um you you wish to speak but can i just
say if it's
very specifically about foreigners again
perhaps that will be dealt with outside
this meeting uh no chair it it was
firstly to thank jasmine for her
presentation and also
for um the conversations we've had since
the tuesday meeting
and it was i was pleasing to see that
some of the comments that we've already
raised in the briefing
and on the telephone are actually in
your slide presentation
so it shows that you've taken on board
what what we're trying to get over
um and it was just to reaffirm our
support in helping and
and working with you for this i think
it's a very worthwhile
um thing to be doing for our coastline
um and just a quick update i have spoken
to fourness on your behalf as i said i
would and they are keen to
get in contact and liaise with you and
they're keen to
as you've mentioned they're keen to find
out the expectations the clarity
they want some safeguarding for
themselves and with the way things
happen
when they are on the water as you've
mentioned in the in the slides
and they're also keen to support uh both
you and the council
in areas of policing this as well um and
i believe they've got a few ideas and
suggestions
uh also bringing on board the coast
guard and the rni
and also there are
official courses you can do like the
royal yachting association
but they're very expensive but they are
looking to create their own
uh formatted qualification that you have
to get before you can even become a
member of the water user group
and they also want to consider putting a
rib out for
for safety on the sea as well uh to be
more proactive so there's lots of good
things that these clubs
wish to do and it's nice to see that and
but they just want to get in contact
with you so
if you can get contact with them um i
think this will move forward
and it will become a very robust and
worthwhile document thank you
thank you councillor moore for not being
specific that's great
um councillor over
okay hi hi jasmine uh nice to see you
again
um thank you again for the update
uh i have a particular interest in peg
well bay
because being on the site of special
scientific interest i wonder if it
receives any particular attention um
or any funding for instance to because
obviously because it's a more sensitive
area
okay thank you
thank you councillor roper yes um so
obviously working with
uh some of our officers like atlantic
coast project officer and our
sam's officer and various other people
who are um looking at some of the
conservation side of things
we are aware that we do need to focus in
some attention at peg well
um and we've got some issues there where
there is some misuse probably going on i
think it's fair to say and there's been
some really interesting
um film footage that's been published
online recently which is quite um
quite concerning so yes i think
in short we're looking at trying to
capture some of the issues there with
some of the other agencies
external agencies that are are concerned
with the locate location
um and trying to to focus in on them
um so the dog pspo covers some of it but
i think again it's down to presence and
having that having that presence there
more more frequently so
um that is certainly something we're
looking at um
yes so hopefully that answers your
question
and does it have any funding specific
funding for that
so um through the through the senate
coast project
obviously there is um particular focus
on on that area
um and the national nature reserve um
and
obviously we have other designations in
the locality there like ramsar and other
important international designations
um in terms of specific funding for that
bay i'm not sure actually so that's
something i'll have to
um find out from from tony child but
that's certainly something to to look
into and
and if we don't then maybe maybe there's
some things we can look at there because
one of the key things there is around uh
signage
and um informing people about what we
expect from them because i
suspect that's a large part of the
problem is people aren't really sure
what they should and shouldn't be doing
there
thank you
councillor huxley
thanks chair thanks jasmine for your
presentation again
i'm just as they've had a lot of um
contact with residents who use the beach
at
ramsgate maine sands mostly from east
cliff ward and
moses montefiore award and um they say
when they swim on the beach sale they
did last summer
the kite surfers were quite dangerous
and there was no sort of you know
management of the beach
um how are you going to enforce that is
that going to be in the beach management
plan rather than the pspo
thanks thank you
councillor um so yes we we do have um
some things planned for ramsgate main
sands one of them is
um putting in a buoyed bathing area
which we hope will provide some
protection for
swimmers over and above what we already
have and we're looking at this at a few
locations not just ramsgate main sands
and part of that is to add that
that extra layer of protection against
any watercraft that kind of do
accidentally come in to the to the
bathing area obviously we also have the
r li who are looking after those beaches
um in the season as well
our enforcement officers will be looking
at dealing with
some of the really specific
water-based activities but i think again
a lot of it is around
code of conduct so they're going to have
to be stopping people challenging them
and reminding them of of what they need
to be doing
um there are some challenges to that
obviously when they're out in the water
and
it's about catching them when they come
back in um if they're launching from our
beaches then we can absolutely deal with
that yes
thank you councillor boyd thank you
thank you again for your presentation
jasmine um just a comment
really in terms of um really piece you
mentioned about um obstructions within
the promise um
the other thing which could be i
classified some kind of obstruction is
actually people
and so just more around how can we
promote more courtesy around how we use
the proms
so we're not getting lines of six people
going on because i know
in various other briefings we've had
complaints about um
cyclics going too fast or not enough way
and i think there's just a
there's a lack of understanding within
the walkers the runners the
disciples as to which side they're meant
to be on
you know and it causes that kind of
friction and obviously you can't tell
people
what to do but in terms of is there any
signs about just being courteous of
other people whether it's
trying to keep to the left or or
whatever and the other point was i
really like the idea of
the um training so and obviously with
the aka between
and i just wondered whether within part
of that you could have almost like a
physical action
within that so whether they go out with
a lipstick and they go and do a bit of a
beach cleaners past fit because
then they might actually feel a bit more
invested to not do it again because
they've had to just go and work a little
bit to help that community
and obviously it doesn't have to be a
spanish one because you want to be known
as
the community payback 1.0 or something
but
you're going to get other charities or
people involved and just
kind of make it a bit more worthwhile
for them to do it
[Music]
yes and part of the aqa course for
littering i believe is spent out
physically outside doing doing a litter
pick so that is already
um proposed as part of it um
so yes and generally using it as an
opportunity to connect people with
the natural environment which is part of
it changing their behavior
in the longer term um so yes um
absolutely
and um the thing about shared shared
space around the proms
we have got a project ongoing at the
moment with kcc
where we've got those um we had stickers
on the problems they're all being
replaced and redesigned but i do think
that there's a bit of extra work there
around
what you say about actually pedestrians
being you know careful of cyclists as
well and it's it's a it's a bit of a you
know
a two-pronged thing really um it's not
always just on cyclists all the time
being irresponsible and going too fast
so
yeah and we have got this code of
conduct and there's a whole
you know load of extra stuff in that but
i think we could probably highlight that
within there
around being sort of courteous
thank you thank you councillor bailey
and my apologies you asked to speak
under 20.1 i should have brought you in
at the beginning so
i i do apologize for that okay thank you
chair
uh thanks jasmine for your presentation
again really useful
um and a really um positive um
initiative
this you've actually answered a lot of
the questions or covered a lot of the
things i was going to say
so thank you for that thank you for
taking on board the um suggestions from
the briefing
the other night especially around
targeted campaigns
and publicizing data and whatever
a couple of specific um questions
regarding the barbecues under condition
2
it says about removing from the beach
and not putting them in the beach bins
will tjc be providing um special
barbecue bins for the beaches that's one
thing
um what's the other question
regarding vehicles on proms
game would it be possible to have pop-up
barriers at the entrances to prevent
unauthorized vehicles because we have a
lot of problems with this
in broad stairs on the prom other
vehicles coming on the prom
and my my main worry as the other night
is still about
the evening activities on the beaches
with the bonfires
drug taking drinks large gatherings
how are we going to enforce that if it's
outside of the enforcement officer's
working hours
so they're my questions thank you um so
first one is a fairly easy one about
um barbecue bins for the beaches so this
is something we've been talking about i
think for quite a few years
and whilst we do want to encourage
people to take stuff home with them
where they possibly can
um obviously once it's cooled down but
um i do think it's something that we do
need to
uh pursue in getting at some of our
locations where we do get a lot of
people barbecuing
um so that's something that um that we
can definitely look into i'm not sure
where we ever got to it
with it in the past so i need to need to
revisit that um
vehicles on prompt we did have pop-up
barriers that we used
um a couple of locations last year to
slow people down and to stop vehicles
and one of them was at west bay
and they weren't necessarily the most
attractive looking things
but they did serve a purpose so they
kind of they're a bit like a concertina
so you can kind of pull them out
and and the bay inspectors had those
they looked after them and they put them
out at the bay
when needed so that's a really quick and
easy way of us doing something
you know just within the season um but
we have put a couple of extra bollards
in
over the winter in various places so
again
if that's something that's more
appropriate because we want to
permanently restrict access somewhere
then
we can potentially look at doing that
where it's not going to obstruct
you know people getting around where
they need to um
so that the pop-up barriers is probably
the easiest way of resolving
resolving that um so we can speak to you
leisure about that and see if that's
something that they can
do again this year um did you say broad
stairs was
probably the place for that yes
there's a lot of um yeah
we have a lot of problems with vehicles
on the prompt broad stairs yeah okay
that's fine so we can yeah
that's the upper problem at the top of
the top
and the final thing is about the
seasonal um out of hours issues with
parties so again
um that's something that a lot of the
time the police will get called to
um but what we are going to try and do
again this year as part of the beach
management plan is a multi-agency
meeting
um and have that sort of um our
responses to particular issues mapped
out ahead of the season so we're not
coming into the season and trying to
address it you know in july and august
when we're in the midst of
all these things happening so just
trying to be a bit more organized really
and
i think some of those things will be
joint ops between us
and the police um that we'll be trying
to
map out ways that we can just you know
target uh hotspot areas again really
and the other the other thing associated
with that is communicating
our worries you know things are going on
do we
so do we call the police in the first
instance in that case if there's
things going on in the beach and social
behavior at night i i think if it if it
was at night i think that probably would
be
um i think most of the work that we
would be looking to do would be
um other kind of slow time more
proactive
um joint initiatives um
but we did we do need to agree on
a mechanism by which members can let us
know quickly about issues
um so we still need to determine what
that looks like but
we do know that's something we need to
do so that is on the list
yeah that's great thank you okay jasmine
a couple of councillors in the the chat
have asked whether there'll be
a dedicated number that counselors can
have they can quickly
contact coast and street scene officers
and
get enforcement action yes
um so again we haven't quite determined
what who who and what that will be and
how that will look and if we have some
kind of
shared you know phone for an on duty
officer or something
but it is something we're looking to try
and find a way around so that members do
have a quick
a quick way in to contact us
thank you i can't see any other members
wishing to comment um jasmine can i
um thank you very much for uh
presentation tonight
you know very clear very comprehensive
um thank you for thinking up questions
that we probably wouldn't have thought
of that that was really good
and uh you know it's good to know that
from the briefing the other night and
from comments that members have made
tonight that you're taking those on
board and that they'll be
fed into the system so thank you very
much
agenda item eight jasmine
you're back again report on the council
with abandoned vehicle process
how can tdc speed up time taken to clear
abandoned vehicles
over to you thank you um i'm not going
to present it for this one i'm just
going to read through the report
um so obviously
um the question has been asked about how
we can speed up the process
um so at the moment um
the process that we have within the
within the parking and enforcement team
um is set based on legislation
um and there's i think there's a lot of
connected issues with this that
um sometimes get a bit a bit confused so
part of one of the actions that we're
proposing is actually we do a bit a bit
more communication around this um
to clarify um what the public need to do
to report and um and what we can do to
deal with some of the issues
and so as i've said in the report
obviously abandoned vehicles often get
confused with nuisance vehicles
and the two things can kind of get a bit
a bit muddled
a nuisance vehicle um you know could
could be any number of
of things depending on a person's
perception really
um but commonly some of the things we
get asked about are vehicles that are
poorly parked for amounts of time
obviously those that cause obstruction
resident disputes things that have
broken down places and have been left
there and those which are untaxed
so the thing about abandoned vehicles is
they are costly to remove
um but we do recognize that they
are negative um in terms of the
perception that they create of a local
environment
um and a lot of the time
uh some of the actions that we we look
at doing are obviously cleaning up
uh locations to try and help reduce
uh the impact of crime and antisocial
behavior
um there are also physical risks to some
of these vehicles being left there so
again we we recognize that some of them
which are dangerous um you know
cause extra concern and we do have
different um ways of dealing with them
more quickly
so we do have um that the main piece of
legislation that we use is obviously
um this one that's listed here which is
the refuse disposal
act 1978 and we
are able to remove abandoned vehicles
on public land as part of that there are
other pla
other pieces of legislation that we can
remove vehicles abandoned on private
land
so under this act um abandoning a
vehicle is a criminal offence
um and we can deal with that through
fines um and obviously
prosecution as well so
the main thing and i i think this is
probably one of the key
things about the issue that we have here
in the process and how long it takes is
when people report an abandoned vehicle
sometimes it doesn't always meet the
criteria so
um it has to not be taxed been in situ
for over two weeks
and doesn't have a known owner and then
that
will then lead on to the type of action
that we might take so obviously for
for something that's dangerous burns out
um leaking or you know
there's other really obvious health
hazards and health and safety hazards
then we've got that 24-hour notice which
we can issue
the seven-day notice is is the thing
that's probably
um the more common one that we would use
um and then the 15-day notice
uh for that if it's on private land
that's where we would need to work
closely with a landowner and sometimes
that's where things can get a bit
complicated and maybe take a bit longer
so all of these things are set by
legislation so they're quite
prescriptive
um and in terms of how quickly we have
to wait between issuing
notices and and people giving people the
chance to respond to those notices and
claim their vehicle or move it
and they're set very strictly and can't
be changed
so the process that we've listed out
here is obviously the at the moment
um reports are made online by members of
the public um
or emails or telephone calls through to
us on our system which get noted by our
officers
and then seven days after that report an
officer will attend and put a notice
physically onto the vehicle and that
gives the the legal notice of the intent
of removal
if someone doesn't come forward in that
time and then
we would request from the dvla uh the
details of the registered keeper
and we have had some delays with this
recently which i think are as a result
of
of covid related issues and
administrative and
resource issues um at the dvla side
potentially
there's been a few blips in the system
and how it would normally work
but generally speaking that's pretty
instantaneous that we can get that
information
and then obviously if there is a
registered keeper then um we would write
to them to advise them what we're going
to do and then that gives them a time
period to claim the vehicle
after that time period of seven days has
gone uh
then we will send one of our officers
out to visit again a second time to make
sure it's still there
um and then we can basically press ahead
with getting it removed
we use a contractor to do this um and
again this is the only other sort of
section of the process where there might
be a delay
is if they couldn't respond immediately
or within a reasonable time frame for
example
and then if a vehicle is claimed during
the process then there's obviously no
further action that we would be able to
take
so the police do have some powers as
well um
and they are obviously able to to act a
bit more swiftly um
under under the powers that they have
and then the time scales as i said are
set out
under under the legislation so there
isn't really any clear way that we could
speed up the process at this time
other than to make the process clearer
for residents and make sure that when
they do report an abandoned vehicle
um that report doesn't come through to
us and and
they need to get a response i think a
bit more quickly to say if it isn't
uh deemed to be abandoned so that
they're not waiting
um for a process to start that actually
isn't isn't going to be able to be
um applicable in in the circumstances
and so i think
really our recommendation is that this
is noted
the process is noted but also that um
we will endeavor to update our website
with a bit more
useful information i think for the
public around
the process okay
jasmine thank you the recommendation is
that
this report is noted and that
communications could be strengthened on
the council's process
to inform residents of the procedures
and time scales we are confined to
under the legislation i think that was
done that would make a
vast improvement i can't see any members
wishing to speak
no nobody's speaking so uh jasmine
i think this is you finished for the
night at last uh can i thank you
once again i mean that the report was
was really clear
um and uh can't thank you enough for all
you've done tonight it's been the
jasmine vickers show and a good show
it's been thank you
thank you okay remembers agenda item a
planning enforcement review why is the
planning enforcement process seemingly
so slow in senate
and how can it be made more efficient
i will call upon deb shotton if she's
here remember the public who wishes to
speak
i do can you hear me i certainly can
um it is really great okay thank you
and starting now um i i did planning at
university so it's an area of interest
of
mine um most particularly this sort of
philosophy
of enforcement and how it can impact um
communities beneficially this is
something we've been hearing from the
jasmine and and with the police
this evening um maintaining self safe
and pleasant environments for everybody
i believe that community engagement in
planning matters impacts hugely on a
local authority's ability to protect
and enhance the lived environment of
their constituents or
immunity in planning pilots
in turn an environment in which its
inhabitants believe they have some say
in how it is managed becomes their
environment
which they will be more inclined to
protect and conserve in their turn
for those of you unfamiliar with the
broken windows theory
the basic principle is that where
visible signs of criminal damage in an
environment such as broken windows
are left unrepaired there is a strong
inclination
for those in that environment to
perceive the crime is okay
and for that level of criminal behavior
to become unacceptable and thus accepted
and even permitted this theory was
adopted by dare i say
rudy giuliani when he was mayor of new
york in the 90s
and it eventually slipped sideways into
a controversial zero tolerance policing
policy
but not before it had been proven in its
purest environmental form to positively
affect crime figures in communities
run down neighborhoods breed criminal
behavior and even littering
as we all know which i've always seen as
the first community insult which kids
learn
will affect perception of their
environment where there is litter people
will drop more
in the same way poorly enforced planning
laws engender badly behave developers
where dodging planning requirements and
environmental obligations becomes
acceptable
i'm under no illusion as regards the
difficulties facing local authorities
charged with enforcement when
insufficient funds
are available however not enforcing
in the first instance is far more input
expensive in the long term we have the
conundrum where if you can't afford to
enforce
then you certainly can't afford not to
enforce
i believe the council must look from up
from current finances
and towards the future where greater
costs await you
rectifying greater wrongs importantly
enforcement should be regarded as an
income stream at its
best efficiently and proactively managed
it should be self-funding
it is also increasingly vital for local
authorities to keep a tight hold on
their development responsibilities
with robert generic zoning planning
reforms and the national infrastructure
commission's tendency to sideline local
planning input
increasingly favoring developers
commercial requirements
over the well-being of the environments
affected
i hope tdc can work across party lines
to ensure that enforcement is used
effectively
for the good of both the council and the
people it serves
thank you thank you miss shot thank you
very much
um ian livingstone
uh thank you chairman i i will i'm not
gonna present my screen
um i'm just gonna go through the report
um so thank you very much for inviting
me to
the open screen panel um just to run
through
um what the report covers it covers
some of the background to the
legislation with regards to planning
enforcement
back to the planning act and then
throughout national guidance
in terms of what constitutes effective
enforcement action and why
it is so important as as we've just
heard about upholding the principles of
public community and also the support
for the planning system and the very
foundations of the built environment
as well as the the natural environment
um the planning enforcement process
at thana is a complaints based service
uh you know we operate uh to balance the
resources that we have
in line with public expectation and the
report does
talk about how planning enforcement is
often
a very emotive topic because of
sometimes the nature of those breaches
are are very significant and really do
affect people's lives
and therefore we categorize complaints
linked to our enforcement protocol which
was appended to the report
on a prioritization basis looking at
high priority cases which income
encompasses issues to do with um
unauthorized works to listed buildings
unauthorized works in conservation areas
unauthorized works that affect people's
living conditions breaches of section
106 agreements
as well as works to um protected trees
without consent as well as potentially
visually prominent development
and then there are low priority cases
which would involve
you know more minor breaches of planning
legislation
so the investigation process itself uh
encompasses
a number of stages the first is
obviously to establish actually whether
or not planning permission is required
or not
and this can become increasingly
complicated
when you start delving into uh the
permitted development rights
um both the the order from 1995 and the
subsequent multitude of amendments that
have occurred
since uh but also it could come down to
fundamentals
of case law and whether or not actually
development has occurred
as a matter of fact and degree um
if a breach has been established
um the first well suppose the second
point is then to seek to resolve the
matter
without formal action where possible so
that is almost government mandated as a
as a a way forward to try and bring
people back into the planning system
getting an application in potentially
for the development that's occurred
to be able to consult on it to be able
to consider it against
the relevant development plan policies
and
material planning considerations um that
is obviously then
the the next the next game um if that
doesn't happen
then it's about deciding whether or not
to take action
or not and that is obviously one of the
critical points in terms of the decision
making of
what happens does it relate to an
enforcement notice being served
or is it the case that a decision is
made in certain instances
and they are you know they are usually
very
a small number whether or not we would
not take action
and giving real cogent reasons why we
have not taken enforcement action
against the particular breaches
themselves um so
i'm not gonna go through um the next bit
of the report which is more talking
about
the background of different types of
notices that can be served because there
are
a number uh as well as how the
enforcement team works within the
council
i think it is important to say that you
know it is
planning enforcement is one element of
the council's work
um but it has very clear linkages with
other sections of the council both in
terms of the work that's carried out
by um you know we've just heard this
evening about some some information
regards to
you know um in this instance cars being
uh being left
you've got street scene enforcement the
enforcement team work with you've got
um you know private sector housing
you've got empty properties
you've got um the work that's done by
community safety you've got obviously
the legal team which plays a
fundamental role in supporting the
planning team so it is
it is something that pervades the
council entirely
um one of the things that that often
comes up
and has been obviously mentioned to some
extent already is about resourcing and
so the report does talk about the
current resources that
the council holds for planning
enforcement so we have two
full-time equivalent members of the play
enforcement team we have an enforcement
officer and an enforcement assistant
they report directly to myself as
planning applications manager
um they are also supported by some work
done by the planning technical team
primarily there to to start the
processing of planning applications but
also
they obviously do assist in some of the
enforcement work that's done
as well as obviously the planning
officers themselves so predominantly
planning officers are dealing with their
own
caseload of between you know 40 to 60
planning applications
um but they do come in and work with
planning enforcement to
look at reasons that go on enforcement
notices whether
a judgment needs to be made as to
whether or not consent would be granted
if um you know if an application wasn't
actually going to come forward
for the breach in itself so there is
resources are brought in but
predominantly the the primary
work done by enforcement is done by two
officers
the report does prepare and or sorry
just provide
um some information gathered
in two separate points one in terms of a
recent um email caller that
um i put out to colleagues of different
local authorities
and also some information that was
provided as a kim planning officers
group meeting in
in december 2019 about resources at
other local authorities so that
information has been provided
and within the report as well um the
report does also talk about
the legal resources um and i think that
is is particularly important
because obviously um you know it is
it's reliant on different resourcing in
different areas as mentioned
but also obviously that is is you know
it has its own limits as well and
obviously the
the report i think it's 4.3 talks about
the resources that are available
um in terms of prosecution for
non-compliance
with enforcement notices or indeed
prosecutions
direct prosecutions that come from say
work unauthorized works to list of
buildings or indeed
works to protected trees
so in terms of section five of the
report that talks about uh complaints
and
formal action and this is where we
started to get into
the the contention put forward um about
the speed of of planning enforcement
and also how it can be made more
efficient so um in
2019 uh the council received 335
complaints
that were logged by the planning
enforcement team um with 78 of those
being
high priority cases uh so see how high
priority cases are
and in 2020 there were 330
complaints with 74 uh high priority
cases um now there is no
defined time scale and service standards
to resolving um an individual
enforcement complaint
now that is because in some instances
uh and this is talked about in mainly in
section
5.3 of the report the complexity
varies greatly with regards to planning
breaches
it can be very very straightforward in
the sense of we can confirm within a
within a 24 hour hour period that
actually that
that doesn't need permission because
that you know boundary fence can be
erected up to a high of two meters
uh if it's not adjacent to a highway or
whatever it be
um but actually some instances of
investigations may take
obviously sometimes a very significant
amount of time
which relates to gathering various bits
of evidence assessing against case law
potentially getting legal advice
interviews under caution and various
different things so there isn't a
set service standard time scale um and
so that complexity can sometimes cause
um certainly i think you know fair
consternation
amongst any complainant um who may be
wondering well what is actually going on
with regards to
the complaints that are going on um and
you know how they are
progressing um the
perception is isn't this is the second
issue which i think
comes to that contention which is about
what is enshrined in the council's
enforcement protocol
and that is again is to try and bring
people back into the planning system
and actually try to assist uh those that
have contravened playing legislation
to actually get them to comply with
planning legislation now that in some
instances that is as straightforward as
saying
remove that entity whatever it be
um if it's not going to be acceptable in
any form
or whatsoever but obviously
it may be about as i said getting an
application to come in
to allow it to be considered against the
development
control framework um there are often
delays outside the control of the local
planning authority
and this um more than not
is resulting in the appeals process so
when we serve an enforcement notice
for a normal it's a regular planning
breach that notice can be appealed
um it may be a case that say a planning
application has come in for
a retrospective planning application has
come in for something and that is
refused then that also can be appealed
um the appeal process can take between
um you know i think between six months
to a year if not longer and in certain
instances it has certainly been longer
with
certain enforcement cases that we've had
and we hold
action in obeyance until after that
appeal because obviously if we were to
require works to occur and then a
planning appeal was to find that
actually no
the development is acceptable the
council would be obviously um
acting in quite a negligent fashion but
that can
naturally hold up what happens and it
may be a case that
if even if an appeal is dismissed
against a notice and the notice is
upheld
it may well be that actually the the you
know the period of compliance of that
notice will start
at the point that the appeal decision is
made and an inspector has the ability to
extend compliance periods over and above
what the council has asked for
um in one instance um from a period of
three months to a period of 15 months
for compliance um which again just
delays after
the the the appeal itself and then i i
you know it is a capacity issue so the
fourth point that i've raised in the
report is about capacity and it is about
the fact that we have to prioritize
given the staff uh and available
resources that we have
um there is a list of enforcement
notices that were served in 2019
and 2020 uh which has come forward which
outlines 26 individual notices
and if um members have had a look at
that they will see that
there are certain instances where those
notices have been complied with
but there are a significant number where
that has either been part complied with
or in fact it has been
not complied with and in a lot of
instances we are
moving through the process um to
actually prosecute
that non-compliance with those notices
um
that obviously again it can be a a
slightly long-winded process and
obviously at the moment
we are still in a situation where the
courts are recovering
after a period of of some cessation but
we are moving through the process to get
some of these cases
uh you know into the courts uh to
you know to act on the non-compliance
with the existing notices that have been
served
so about the the the second point of
um the the contention which is about
what can be done to make the system more
efficient
and so section seven of the report talks
about this
um specifically with regards to an
enforcement review that
um actually sort of it's
it's sometimes wonderful these come
things come about at the same time
because it's something that actually
um was was due to occur last year but
due to circumstances uh
didn't and then we've subsequently had a
decision which has
um raised the point that we should be
looking into
the planning enforcement service and
making sure that we're reviewing our
processes and procedures to ensure that
they are
as efficient as possible and so 7.3 in
the report
talks about a staged approach to
assessing planning enforcement at
that um one of those the first bit is a
general review
and so playing enforcement protocol
that's appended to the report
um was agreed or actually updated last
in 2015
now the principles behind it still hold
firm they are still the ones enshrined
by government guidance
but that uh enforcement protocol is
looking to be
reviewed to ensure that it is
sufficiently up to date and sufficiently
maybe encompasses
uh some of the ways that we're looking
to communicate with members of the
public
in terms of looking at um outlining what
we are doing and also
how we will respond to complaints um it
will also include a process mapping uh
exercise to go through and understand
about um
the the journey of the complainant in
terms of when they would be updated
about certain action being taken and
when not
and this then links to the second phase
which is about our use of systems so
we use the planning database
which holds all details about
applications to record enforcement
complaints
um we are going to be investigating and
this came up
last night's planning committee about
how we can both
try and integrate um that system with
further use that we're using at the
moment
of google in terms of recording uh
information and getting the evidence
ready
for for certain cases um but also about
how we can potentially put that
information
online um where to give those updates
um as we do with planning applications
so you can log in and see what the state
of the planning application is
when the deadlines are and those sorts
of things in the same way
that same public access service is
available and some councils do use it to
publicize about enforcement
in terms of either case closed has a
notice been served if so here's the
notice
obviously there's a limited amount of
information we provide because in some
instances
these are um criminal investigations
effectively because of the
the nature of the breaches um so the
information is slightly limited
but that is an option that we would be
looking at to again to try and open up
to make it clear
what's going on at what stage
enforcement complaints
are at it would also include looking at
the council's website
potentially filtering the information
that comes into us and potentially
provides
automated updates for certain queries
that may come in
if possible about um low-level breaches
and
where further advice can be found about
what is permitted development for
example
although that does seem to continue to
change as the government moves forward
with various bits and pieces um
and then the last point is going to be
once all that work has been done
it is about looking at service standards
and whether or not it would be
appropriate
to dictate certain service standards
potentially for certain types of
complaints and whether or not that would
um would result in the correct outcomes
um with regards to process because
obviously um
certain instances it would be foolish to
rush into action which would cost the
council more and also would
jeopardize more long-term action on
certain issues
but at the same time complaints and
investigations cannot be open-ended we
are time limited
and it's a long time period of four
years for operational development in 10
years for the changing use of the land
from when
um the breach has actually occurred um
but
it is important that we don't have a
enforcement uh
you know process that drags itself out
and again
that obviously does have an impact of
eroding public confidence
in the planning system um but it would
also be a case of looking at in
conjunction with
talking to other sections especially
obviously we've talked about illegal
and obviously the involvement of finance
and other voters in the council about
whether or not there is
an argument to formulate a business case
for additional resourcing
or external funding and those sorts of
things
um and that would be part of the
enforcement review as well
so that's a sort of run through the the
report itself
and i'm happy to answer any questions
through the chair
okay lovely thanks ian thank you very
much um
speaking of the 20.1 councillor ghana
thank you yeah thank you um i'm
i'm pleased we have this opportunity to
discuss the planning enforcement
function at
tdc this evening um since being
elected i've had a number of
interactions with the two and
two members of the team and i certainly
appreciate how hard they work
18 months ago we all voted to declare a
climate emergency and have since been
proposing policy amendments to the local
plan
to further protect our natural
environment and enhance the biodiversity
across the district
many of these new policies will result
in planning applications being
passed with tougher climate emergency
biodiversity conditions it is vital
that not only do we work with developers
to make sure they understand what we
expect of them
but also that we have an enforcement
function that makes sure
that they do what's expected as it
stands i do not believe the team is
equipped to be able to do this
currently the enforcement team works in
a reactive
rather than a proactive way as ian has
explained
on the whole once a planning application
is passed
developers are left to get on with it
and enforcement officers only get
involved
if they receive a complaint from a
member of the public
looking at some of the documentation
attached to the agenda which ian has
gone through
it's easy to see why tdc's enforcement
team of two
is indeed the smallest in the county
i of course accept that we are under
enormous financial pressures
due to central government cuts and to
pressures
brought about by the pandemic but the
same pressures though
are faced by all other kent districts
like dover and ashford
who each employ four officers for this
vital function
we know that over the next few years
there are likely to be a number of very
large developments approved
and we will need a larger proactive
planning enforcement function at tdc
to make sure these developments are
delivered in line with the new local
plans climate emergency and biodiversity
conditions
i would like to suggest that we set up a
scrutiny project
urgently to conduct a proper open review
into the effectiveness of the
enforcement function within planning as
a whole
and to explore ways in which it can be
expanded and improved
and i would ask members to consider this
during their discussion
this evening thank you
thank you councillor garner councillor
moore yes thank you chair and thank you
ian for your presentation
um my query is four-fold so i hope
you've got a pen handy
and maybe you'd like to answer them in
order um
with any planning application we have to
pay a planning fee
and so why is it not that if someone
doesn't have a planning application
and obviously enforcement is a reactive
process
why are we not penalizing them by
finding them is it something that we
could do or is it this government led
uh through law because if someone is
fined for not having the appropriate
planning application
that would be something to deter them
the second one is continuity of
enforcement
um i i know of two properties within
four door area one was made to remove
their upvc windows
the second property was reported and
they've seemingly got away with it
um so is there a sort of a deadline time
scale where
enforcement expires and you cannot no
longer do it because i know you
mentioned that
there's no time scale for enforcement
but how long do we have to leave it
before you take those people to task
because
if it's there for years or two years
surely we're running beyond the time
scale
of being diligent in bringing them to
order
and lastly as we mentioned at the
planning application form
it would be nice to see when these uh in
these enforcement or reactive
uh plans are produced that we can see an
update because i know your team is out
of two
but as i said before it'd be nice where
the councils could go on somewhere log
in
with a password and see how these um
applications are progressing or how the
enforcement team are progressing
with dealing with them thank you
did you want to respond to that ian yes
thank you chair um
so the first point about finding it's it
is governed by national legislation
so planning for applications um require
a fee for processing that fee is
nationally set
um provisions aren't there in national
legislation for
fines to be imposed by local planning
authorities for
enforcement breaches so we don't have
the power to do it um
i'm going to say unfortunately i'm going
to say that because i think that's
you know it's it's something but it's
it's not under our gift unfortunately
and the second point about um continuity
i take councillor moore's point um
i think that we do want to ensure that
we are being consistent
and but obviously there are going to be
sometimes
um sometimes intricate differences
between different cases even when they
may be in a very very
um small radius um
i think the point about time scales is
that um
from a breach occurring uh we have four
years
in which to take action so serving a
notice and that's the important thing
it's not about
us um asking them to remove it it's the
serving of the notice and the notice
going on the register
um after four years it becomes lawful by
virtue of the fact that we haven't taken
enforcement action
um so again it's not our intention to
make
enforcement investigations last for four
years um because obviously that just
wouldn't make any sense whatsoever
but obviously in terms of when we get to
certain complaints and this
is why we look to prioritize it's about
ensuring that if it's
say in this example probably in a
conservation area
that we are acting on it within a timely
fashion to move things forward and
especially if there are
instances in the surrounding area where
it's happening because
as referenced by the member of the
public it can be a case that these
things do spread and obviously we don't
want that to happen and we want the
public perception of certain areas
that are designated like conservation
areas uh to be upheld
and to pick up the point about um access
for
members um to information
that is exactly one of the points of the
of the review
um in terms of this this idea of public
access to enforcement information which
would obviously be available to
um ward councillors as well uh there are
as i say councils that are using it um
members can visit um off the top mate i
think
southampton was one that i was looking
at who use the same program as last to
say it looks it will look very similar
to the planning uh the planning pages on
on
um uh on the planet's website in terms
of searching and planning application
but you can search enforcement cases as
well
so that is something that we are
certainly looking into we
don't have um the access through the
current system to do that and so there
is going to be would be a cost
implication to that but that will be
part of the review to work out how it
could be funded
uh potentially to provide if it would
provide the benefits that we think it
would
thank you councillor huxley
thank you chair thanks ian for your
presentation
um i think you've made the case for
having more planning enforcement
officers shortly at tdc
um compared to david district council
which has probably similar problems to
us
listed buildings etc they have four
officers
full-time officers we only have two
surely there is a business case for
increasing our staff numbers
both in planning enforcement and in
legal
departments and i think it's a good idea
as other people have said like council
ghana to put a
planning enforcement notices on the ttc
website
so we can search on those just like
planning applications
and councillor ghana i agree with him i
think there should be some sort of
working party from scrutiny
to look into these issues thanks a lot
okay um councillor kane thank you chair
yeah i mean i also wanted to support
councillor ghana's idea that this
should be scrutinized because it does
seem there's a good case for looking
at the um a number of people we've got
for enforcement of this but i also
wanted just to raise
on the bigger developments that we've
had
um and obviously we've got more coming
through where
the pictures that we're given for
planning
have lots of nice landscaping and play
areas and that
but often they don't seem to be
delivered in quite that way or
very slow to be delivered and if you've
got any comments
on that and how that is enforced
currently
thank you
um i think to pick up the point with
regards to
landscaping the big bigger developments
and linking into cancer gardens point as
well
we do have a um within the playing
applications team we have a planning
assistant who predominantly deals with
planning conditions so
through the submission of conditioned
details that's a sort of it's a
lower level consent regime and that that
officer does work very closely with the
enforcement team as well because
obviously if
going out on site et cetera and will
discover
that something hasn't been done in terms
of the um
you know whatever the planning
permission requires may well result in
obviously an enforcement investigation
occurring um yes it is it is the case
that obviously the council has
large strategic allocations we have
currently planning applications that are
under consideration for
significant scale developments as well
as developments that have already been
granted
planning permission which will have um
quite significant areas
of housing development as well as open
space and landscaping
so it is going to be imperative that all
elements of
the the planning team both the planning
officers who
you know wrote the conditions the
conditions officer and also planning
enforcement are all involved
in actually making sure the development
turns out as was proposed and as was
approved
yes thank you thank you okay
counselor
um in the light of some of the other
councillors comments can i propose a
scrutiny review
of enforcement please
is that possible uh council roper
i i mean i think it's clear that there
is a a will
amongst members for a scrutiny review
but like all other
areas of the council you know scrutiny
has limited resources as well
um what i'd like to propose is that
i take away the sentiment that we would
like a scrutiny review
and discuss with officers uh you know
what the scope of that review may be
what resource we would need to
service it and bring back to the next
scrutiny
committee a proposal um
hopefully that we will carry out a
review or
to explain why perhaps at this point in
time we wouldn't be able to
um we did at one stage suggest that um
you know we would have
one sort of side operation going at a
time and we've still got
the memorials working party working i
think that may be coming to an end
of its work but um if members would
agree
um i'll take away the sentiment and
bring back a proposal
to the next scrutiny meeting the members
agree with that
thank you thank you chair thank you can
see quite a lot of nodding
um i can't i can't see any other
questions of people when you speak
ian can i thank you um your second late
night
you'll be getting used to this um thank
you very much for that you know very
comprehensive report
um and uh you know obviously
i'll be talking to you with other
officers about uh what sort of review we
we might do i think
there's definitely a will to have that
from the the panel
so could i ask members to
note the report and the fact that we
will be bringing back a proposal
regarding the review that agreed
thank you thank you very much um gender
item 10
review of the isp work programme this
has been published
i asked members to note the report
lots of nodding that's great thank you
and gender item 11 forward plan and
exempt cabinet report list for period 9
december 20 20 31st of may 2021
it says on here unless there's something
from the plan that the panel would wish
to consider
members are asked to note the report
lots of nodding so thank you very much
members officers
a member of the public it's been a very
long evening i think a very good
evening very interesting evening so
thank you for your contributions
and i wish you good night thank you very
much indeed bye-bye
good night everyone